[Music]
this morning on the dish steve
phelps born and raised near cleveland
phelps eventually moved to the west
coast of florida
and has since created one of the most
unique dining experiences in the nation
while
racking up honors along the way twice
named a james beard semi-finalist for
best chef in america
his restaurant in sarasota is called
indigenous
if you're lucky enough to get a
reservation get ready for some of the
best seafood
in the land so this is the pompano
nigiri ready for this one jeff oh my
goodness
so we've got sweet soy we've got a
szechuan chili oil
and then there's a yuzu gastrique which
is a japanese citrus that's really
really bright
and you got the sea purslane on top with
some fiera cocky with sesame seeds and
nori
so just get it all in your mouth it's a
work of arts right here
wow the impeccable balance that steve
phelps brings to his food
is something he's been cultivating since
he was a teenager but really took off
about 20 years ago
when he and his wife left their home
outside cleveland for what they thought
was going to be a short trip
to florida i think we spent an afternoon
that day
at the beach and saw a dolphin jump up
in front of us and were
enlightened and said wow this is pretty
nice fast forward
almost 20 years later and i'm sitting
with you outside my restaurant now
indigenous was opened in 2011 in a
residential neighborhood in sarasota
which has long had a thriving arts
community phelps set out to create
a seafood oasis the word indigenous when
people think florida they think citrus
and citrus is not indigenous to florida
correct indigenous ingredients here you
know for florida really were the rice
and the corn and things like that
and it's tough because there's a lot of
confusion with that and i have to say it
as a chef because i get a lot of calls
and they go
do you make native american dishes all
day there but
indigenous to us means that it is from
the era or native to the area and that's
what we do with all the food that we can
how do you describe your food philosophy
my food is
food that's recognizable and i think
responsible is a name that we like to
use
one example his support of local
farm-raised
fish which haven't always had the best
reputation
that is changing fast as conditions
inside
aquaculture farms improve dramatically
and as the global demand for seafood has
doubled in the last 60 years i'm so
fascinated by the technology that they
do
these recirculating tanks that they use
these fish never stay in the same water
the feeds have come so far advanced in
technology with what they're utilizing
in those two
we've got so many different species and
i rely on them
as a restaurant owner because my menus
have to
continuously have an item on there do
you think fish farming
is the future it is i'm afraid
of what's happening out on our waters
the pollution in the water
the quotas for the fishermen they're all
starting to get pollution is getting
higher
quota's getting smaller and we're going
to need that protein
from a relatively small kitchen phelps
turns out an incredible variety
from all that seafood to these
ridiculously good
beignets there you go jeff try one of
those bad boys
oh my lord whoa and there's more
we'll let him do the honors on the
larger spread he prepared
we've got some cobia hot dogs with a
little local sauerkraut
and some cleveland burtman's mustard we
spice it with some pastrami spices a
little baked shrimp and scallops with
everglades butter
this is barrel fish over a bacon potato
latke with a little yuzu hollandaise and
jerk relish
our house pickles this is redfish over
kangaroo and pen uh midlands with a
little nashville hop butter
and a little hot drizzle those are
beignets we discussed
uh this is a green curry fish dip that
we do here and a little bit of
sesame nori crackers our tribute to
strawberry shortcake is that panna cotta
with some
florida strawberries and some sweetened
biscuit crumble
we had that in the gear with the pompano
earlier a little
thai crispy pork belly with fish sauce
and thai
fish sauce caramel and a baked egg and
then that's our wild mushroom bisque
which is
a big staple here we've made that for
years a couple cold brews from colusa
our local brewery
and then of course i have to have
buckeyes on my menu being a
ohio state boy and so we've got a little
raspberry jam and some banana
cashew crunch underneath those now i
work with a michigan
fan i'm i'm a little worried about how
that's going to go over but
it looks delicious to me we've had
quite a few michigan people in here say
that they really enjoyed it if phelps
can convince his arch enemies to eat and
love his food
there may be no limits on what he can
shoot for buckeyes and beer
that's a thing right it is today should
we toast to the beer and eat a bucket
cheers though for him
it's always going to be bigger than just
what's on the plate
you say that education is just as
important as the actual food
that you're serving here what's the most
important message that you want to get
across
making your your dining experience and
your choices
good for the planet i think that's one
thing that we've always put emphasis on
here people ask a lot of questions in
our restaurant
and i'm lucky enough to have a staff
that wants to educate a guest as well as
i do
and our wild fish tonight red snapper
from madeira beach
caught off a boat called the fish
busters and if you know that
a chef is educated and a staff is
educated can teach you about
where things come from why we utilize it
and it's good for your body and the
planet that means we just did our job
today and we thank steve phelps that
indigenous just a great guy
dana you don't have to cheer for the
buckeyes but you do have to eat buckeyes
when you come back i will happily as a
wolverine yeah as a wolverine i'll
happily devour buckeyes no problem there
no problem there all right dinner
together at indigenous
it's booked